so
can we try to talk about part of it is
the problem of the word selfishness but
let's
talk about the virtue of selfishness so
let's start at the fact that for me
i really enjoy doing stuff for other
people i enjoy
being uh cheering on the success of
others
why i don't know it's deeper than that
about it why
because i think you do know if i were to
really think
i i don't i don't want to resort to like
evolutionary arguments like this
so i i think
so i can tell you why i enjoy helping
others
maybe you can go there like one thing
because we should talk about love a
little bit
i'll tell you there's a part of me
that's a little bit
not rational like there's a gut that i
follow
that uh not everything i do is perfectly
rational like for example my dad
uh criticizes me he says like you should
always have a plan
like it should make sense you have a
strategy and
and i say that you know i left i stepped
down for my full salary position at mit
i there's so many things i did without
like a plan it's a gut
it's like i want to start a company well
you know how many companies fail
i don't know it's the gut
and the same thing with being kind to
others is
is a gut i i watch the way that karma
works in this world
that the people like us one guy i look
up to is joe rogan
that he does stuff for others and that
the joy he experiences the way he sees
the world
like just the the the glimmer in his
eyes because he does stuff for others
that creates a joyful experience and
that somehow is seems to be an
instructive
way to that to me is inspiring of a life
while living but you probably know a lot
of people who have done stuff others
were not happy
true so i don't think it's the doing
stuff for others that it brings to
happiness it's why you do stuff for
others and what else you're doing in
your life
and and what what is the what is the
proportion
but it's why at the end of the day which
is which is and it's the same
look you can you can maybe through a gut
feeling say i want to start a company
but you better start doing thinking
about how and what and all of that
and to some extent the why because if
you really want to be happy doing this
you may
better make sure you're doing it for the
right reason so
i'm not you know there's something
called fast thinking uh they're calling
the
the the the the daniel kahneman yeah
yeah daniel common talks about and and
there is it's it's it's
you know all the integrations you've
made so far in your life cause you to
have
specialized knowledge in certain things
and you can think very fast
and and and your gut tells you what that
what the right answer is it's but it's
not it's it's
your mind is constantly evaluating and
constantly working
um you want to make it as rational as
you can not in the sense that i have to
think through every time i make a
decision
but that they've so programmed my mind
in a sense
that the answers are the right answers
you know
in in in when i get them um
so you know i like
i view other people as a value
other people contribute enormously to my
life
uh whether it's a romantic love
relationship
or whether it's a friendship
relationship or whether it's just
you know jeff bezos creating amazon and
and delivering goodies to my home when i
get them and
and and people do all that right it's
not just jeff bezos
he gets the most credit but everybody in
that chain of command everybody at
amazon
is working for me i love that i
love the idea of a human being i love
the idea that there are people capable
of of being an einstein of being you
know and and creating and building and
making stuff
that makes my life so good i you know
most of us like this is not a good room
for an example
most of us like plants right we like
pets i don't particularly but people
like pets why
we like to see life yeah
human beings are life on steroids right
they're life with a brain
it's amazing right what they can do i
love
people now that doesn't mean i love
everybody because there's some
they're really bad people out there who
i hate right and i do hate
and they're people out there that are
just i have no opinion about but
generally the idea of a human being to
me is a phenomenal idea when i see a
baby
i light up because to me there's a
potential
you know uh there's a there's this
magnificent potential that is embodied
in that
and when i see people struggling and
need help
i think they're human beings you know
they embody that potential they embody
that
goodness they might turn out to be bad
but why would i ever give the
presumption of that i give them the
presumption of the positive and i cheer
them on
and and i and i and i enjoy watching
people succeed i
enjoy watching people get to the top of
the mountain and produce something
even if i don't get anything directly
from i enjoy that because it's
part of my enjoyment of life so the word
see to you the morality of selfishness
this kind of love of other human beings
the love of life
fits into a morality of selfishness
can't not
because it it's it you there's no
context in which you can
truly love yourself without loving
life and loving what it means to be
human
so you know the love of yourself is
going to manifest itself differently in
different people but it's
core what do you love about yourself you
first of all i love i love that i'm
alive i love that i you know i not love
this
world and the opportunities it provides
me and the the fun and the
excitement of discovering something new
and meeting a new person and
and having a conversation you know all
of this is
is is is immensely enjoyable but behind
all of that is a particular human
capability that not only i have
other people have and the fact that they
have it makes my life so much more fun
because
so it's it's you cannot view
you know it's all integrated and you
cannot view yourself in isolation now
that doesn't
that doesn't place a moral commandment
on me
uh help everybody who's poor that you
happen to meet in the street it doesn't
place a
burden on me in a sense that now i have
this
model duty to help everybody it leaves
me free to make decisions about who i
help and who i don't there's some people
who i will not help there's some people
who i do not wish
positive things upon bad people should
have
bad outcomes bad people should suffer
so and you have the freedom to choose
who's good who's bad within your
decision based on your values now i
think there's an objectivity to it
there's a there's a standard by which
you should evaluate good
versus bad and that standard should be
to what extent do they contribute or
hurt human life
the standard is human life and so when i
say look at jeff bezos i say he's
contributing to hipaa life
good guy i might disagree with him on
stuff we might disagree about politics
we might disagree about women we're not
just i don't know what we
agree but overall big picture
he is pro-life right i look at somebody
like you know to take
like 99.9 of our politicians
and they are pro-death they are
pro-destruction
they are pro-cutting corners in ways
that destroy
human life and human potential and human
ability so i literally hate
almost every politician out there and i
wish
ill on them right i don't want them to
be successful or happy i want them all
to
go away right leave me alone so
i believe in justice i believe good
things should happen to good people and
bad things should happen to bad people
so
i ca i make those generalizations based
on this one
you know on the other hand if you know i
shouldn't say all politicians right
so if i you know i love thomas jefferson
and and george washington right
i love abraham lincoln i love people who
fought for freedom and who believed in
freedom and had these ideas and
lived up to at least in parts of their
lives to those principles now
do i think tommy jefferson was flawed
because he held slaves absolutely
right but the virtues way outweigh that
in my view and i understand people who
don't accept that
you don't have to also love and hate the
entirety of the person there's parts of
that person that you
that you're trying the major part is
pro-life and therefore i'm pro-that
person
and and i think and i said earlier that
objectivism's philosophy of love and i i
believe that because
objectivism is about your life about
loving your life about embracing your
life about engaging with the world about
loving the world in which you live about
win-win relationships with other people
which
means the large extent loving the good
in other people and the
and the best in other people and
encouraging that and supporting and
promoting
it so i know selfishness is a harsh
word because the culture has given it
that harshness
selfishness is a harsh word because the
people who don't like selfishness want
you to believe it's a harsh word
but it's not what does it mean it means
focus on self it means take care of self
it means make yourself
your highest priority not your only
priority because in taking care of
yourself
what would me what what would i be
without my wife
what would i be without the people who
who who
support me who help me who who who i
have these love
relationships with
you